might just be the end of the 12-year
reign of the israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
he has had numerous opportunities to
form a coalition government
that has failed there have been four
elections in the space of
two years and all of them have ended
unsuccessfully for netanyahu
he has divided public support at the
same time he
is in the middle of a corruption trial
which hasn't
lent him any particular brownie points
and although there was a recent war
between israel
and gaza that you might have thought
would have lent him support because
netanyahu of course always presenting
himself as the strong man
it doesn't seem to have done that now at
exactly 35 minutes before the midnight
deadline expired the country's
opposition leader
yai lapid informed president reuven
rivlin that he was
able to form the next government at the
same time he is urging the parliament to
hold a special session
soon in which they will confirm the
incoming government
technically this is not a done deal
until that parliament session is held
you also have a coalition that
crosses the entire spectrum from the
political right to the political left so
even
if this new government goes forward
there are questions being asked about
how successful
and how long it will last but certainly
the one thing that all these political
parties have in common
is a united front against netanyahu
as for netanyahu assuming that he is
ousted from power
he will then become the leader of the
opposition he will not be able to
introduce
any kind of parliamentary immunity and
at the same time it is expected that the
new government
is going to push for new legislation
that will limit
the number of terms of office that a
prime minister can serve
and at the same time will prevent an
official who has
charges against him from holding office
so certainly a lot happening and
potentially a lot could happen
in the coming days